political earthquake in wyoming that
could have major implications for the
midterms and beyond liz cheney getting
clobbered by trump back candidate
harriet hageman in the state's gop
primary by almost a 40-point landslide
but chaney trying to spend the loss into
a win with her eyes on national office
it that's a decision that i'm going to
make in the in the coming months
savannah i'm not going to make any
announcements here this morning but but
it is something that i i'm thinking
about and i'll make a decision in the
coming months
former president trump gloating over the
loss of one of his most vocal political
foes calling cheney a fool who should be
ashamed of herself but chaney is
throwing punches right back and promises
to keep fighting
i believe that donald trump continues to
pose a very grave threat and risk to our
republic i am absolutely going to
continue this battle i think it's the
most important thing i've ever been
involved in and i think it's it's
certainly the most important thing
challenge that our nation has faced in
recent history
and maybe since the civil war
and it's one that we must win
democrats in the media getting called
out for mourning the loss of a cheney
who was once a major villain to the left
i don't think it's an exaggeration to
say this is potentially as dangerous a
moment for this country as we've seen at
any time since the middle of the 19th
century in the run-up to the civil war
it's about 38 39 percent of the
electorate
that want to replace the us government
that want to throw away american
democracy i respect enormously her
commitment to democracy instead of her
commitment to one man that tells you a
lot about the state of the republican
party in this country right now
and how extreme and how devoted to
donald trump it is
so there are a lot of
elements to this loss dana i want to
come to you about something that was
just mentioned in that clip about liz
jean's commitment to democracy
so i have a lot of thoughts i was born
in wyoming have family there um served
with liz and of course worked
in the white house when dick cheney was
vice president so all those things being
said like i taking myself out as an
analyst and looking at this okay one
thing wyoming voters are hyper concerned
about is wyoming right and there had
been a lot of talk over the past year
and a half that that was one thing that
she was not focused on
and it was permeating the entire
electorate then you had the trump pile
on the disdain between the two of them
is very real
i would love for everyone to get along
that is just not the real world and um i
i could never run for office because i
could not probably do all of the things
that anybody running for offices i think
it takes a lot of guts um but when ron
klain says that he admires her
commitment to democracy like actually
that's what happened yesterday in
wyoming yes this is democracy
and there was an election there were a
primary
and there was two different approaches
to winning the primary and the only
question really was was she going to
lose by 30 points or 40 points and it
turned out to be 40. i'm not sure of a
constituency going forward in terms of
running for president obviously may be
premature but i understand everybody
wants to keep their options open for
whatever happens but i find it really
hard to imagine that
those media people that we just showed
are going to vote for somebody who's for
smaller government and low taxes that's
not what that's not why they respect her
and
by then
there's not going to be a probably a
president trump by then because if he
wins a second term and she wants to run
again i mean that's like
if she runs after that there won't be
even a reason to do that
the other thing i would say is
wyoming is a it's a special place
it's a low population state but there's
a lot of people moving in there and you
see where in jackson hole that's where
almost all the votes came from the rest
of the state is not jackson hole and
it's going to be an easy win for hegemon
in november and she will be the next
republican congresswoman from wyoming
absolutely true um judge i want to talk
to you a little bit about harriet
hageman she was a never trumper at the
start she called him a racist and a
xenophobe and then i guess you know she
found trump culture um and now is going
to be the new congressman from wyoming
what do you think this election
was really about did she win it or did
liz cheney yeah
i i think that when you look at these
numbers and i ran for office five times
i mean the the
cheney got clobbered she got clobbered
wyoming said we don't want any part of
you we don't want any part of your
agenda and remember she out-raised
hegemon i mean she had a lot of money
she had a lot of support she knew how to
run hagerman had only won a run once or
twice before that hageman in fact had
had worked with cheney uh and the truth
is that cheney lost and i think it's
very interesting that she would actually
think that she has a chance as a
presidential candidate because they can
blow smoke all over her and tell her how
wonderful she is and democracy right now
is where it should be but if you think
the democrats are going to support liz
cheney
that's never going to happen the truth
is that that they used her for their own
agenda they used her to trounce trump
and trump is just winning across the
board across the country so i don't
think there is a future for liz cheney
when you don't work for the constituents
that you work for but you you assess or
you you assess that you are there for
some higher political agenda then you
know then you're not really a public
servant you're an ideologist
greg to the judge's point about who she
would represent because i know everyone
loves that phrase um
so as a democrat
i would not vote for liz cheney and i
wouldn't vote for andrew yang either
both of them would be third party
spoilers in this that would probably get
more independents and probably
conservative democrats peeled off than
republicans um what do you think and you
have a lot of notes i know you have
things that you want to say but start
with at least the impact of the trump
endorsement and what you think that
carry over to the midterms will be
okay
she compared this to the civil war
she is nuts okay there she is overtaken
with such obsession and such emotional
bitterness that she has this kind of
grandiose view of herself and it's
actually now getting embarrassing it's
embarrassing for her i wish she had a
friend that could take her aside and say
you got us calm down don't run for
office you're not going to get a
national office at best you're going to
get office depot the republicans hate
you the democrats don't want you this is
all driven by some emotional brokenness
that happened from trump she goes all
the way back to the civil war of course
she didn't mention the iraq war or the
afghanistan war because that cuts a
little too close to home or to dad so
she goes back and then she compares
herself to abe lincoln she i mean people
say that trump has an ego but when he
says stuff like that it's usually with a
wink and then everybody's laughing
there's nothing in her eye but spites
it's like it's such a personal vendetta
from day one and i get it trump had no
use for the cheneys and the cheney's had
no use for trump i get it but the party
has moved on from this sort of thing she
hasn't we've heard about this it's a
struggle is to the civil war we've been
told it's the end of democracy trump
supporters are evil adam kinzinger said
that two days ago he said trump
supporters are evil and she's fighting
evil how is that
how is that not incitement
you can cr you can't criticize the fbi
but you can smear millions of people
because orange hitler right and i guess
she does have something in common with
abe lincoln they both allowed theater to
kill them and her theater was january
6th and she
i don't know what she's going to do next
but i would consider taking a break do
not listen to democrats do not listen to
the media because they're just going to
use you i think she's starting her own
pack which is hilarious but normal
people don't get that emotional over
this stuff and i think that she needs
just
somebody should just pull her back and
go look everybody's moved on except for
you
it's time maybe that's me maybe she's
listening to me maybe i could be her
friend maybe top advisor yeah i could be
i could be i could be part of her pack
uh it's gonna say well
sean quickly on the most critical issue
in this campaign which was election
denialism the big lie and when you look
ahead to the midterms in the background
states two-thirds of the gop nominees
that have made it through their
primaries deny that president biden
legitimately won this election
you know but i think when you look at
this race jessica and this goes to a
point that dana made this is about
wyoming right and dick cheney came out
with an ad for full liz and it was all
about donald trump he said nothing about
wyoming so if you're going to run to say
hey i want to represent you i want to
make your life better that's what
politics is about how do i make your
life better but inflation is raging in a
rural area where i was from in wisconsin
gas prices crush people who are in the
middle class um she did nothing to fight
for those issues for them and if you're
gonna run for higher office you have to
have charisma she has no christmas i
served with her she listen she's a drip
um she's smart but she's a drip she's
going nowhere she might run for dog
catcher and probably wouldn't win but
she's not running for president and to
to talk about the threats to the country
i mean i'm sorry yeah you might not like
donald trump yes january 6 happened but
when you look at
you know politicizing the doj we had 10
terrorists that we know of that came
across the border last month alone there
are real risks that are happening we're
going to spend ourselves into oblivion
we're going to see hyperinflation those
are all issues that affect families that
democrats are driving that i think
should be addressed and to say that
donald trump is the problem i think
she's missing the boat into just one
last point to your point democrats used
her um to drive a narrative on donald
trump think of john mccain john mccain
thought the left loved him too he was
going to run and democrats going to come
and support him
once once john mccain ran for president
they threw him out and they attacked him
and by the way where was the media
saying joe manchin is full of courage we
love joe manchin supporting democracy
they attacked joe manchin when he when
he stood up to democrats but oh gosh we
got to we got a republican that will
stand up to uh to other republicans and
there for democracy and they have
courage it's all garbage
couple things so the inflation reduction
act uh reduces the deficit by 300
billion and duly noted
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now